hello everyone thank you for coming it's
great to be here with you
i hope to inspire you just a little bit
to write
more pythonic code
so let's start this discussion by
thinking of
writing pythonic code and working with
these ideas of pythonic code
as empathetic ways of working with your
co-workers
right how many of you came from a
language like
c or java or c sharp
a decent number right when you first
learned python
you probably thought it was this really
simple thing that you could learn right
away like
oh i spent a weekend now i know python
right
you now know how to do things in python
but you don't know python right
and so a lot of these ideas are sort of
algorithms or ways of working
that you might come from another
language and then write code that way
until you know better
all right so these are ways that you can
help your co-workers or maybe yourself
become a little bit better at writing
python the way it was meant to be
written
so let's start by just defining you know
what is pythonic right this is the
question people
often ask when they come to python like
i hear this term pythonic
i know it means it's better but what
does that mean
so every language has idioms or ways of
writing
code that is sort of accepted by the
community right there's many ways to
write programs and
implement algorithms and so on but there
are ways that are more right and they're
ways that are less right
for the particular language you're
working with and for python i think it's
especially
important because it's such a simple and
readable language
that when you use it wrong it's stands
out more
i guess rather than say let's say c
right so when we write code that
embraces these
idiomatic ways of working that's what
pythonic code is right
so when you write code like this there's
many many advantages to it
first of all you're taking advantage of
thousands of very smart developers
years of experience i say thousands not
millions even though there are
millions of python developers not every
one of them
is sort of contributing back to open
source contributing back to the
community but at
thousands hundreds of thousands i don't
know but it's really great to leverage
what has worked for
these experienced developers okay so
when you
take advantage of these idioms of the
language you're working the way that
these people have found to be the best
you're also writing code that is
expected by python
and it's tuned to run that type of code
right you could create a sublist by
slicing or you could create a sub list
with a for loop
slicing is probably better it's expected
by the language things like that
now i say see python not general python
because there's
iron python jython pi pi
python.net micropython there are many
things
i'm not necessarily saying it's
optimized for all of those right
although they all have some similarities
but certainly
see python the main one it's also
important that it's easily read and
understood
so when you see common patterns right oh
i see this list comprehension
you immediately know what the intent of
that whole block of code is before you
parse all the symbols right but if you
do something non-pythonic you have to
like
go through and analyze how that code
works right so that's not so great
it's often cleaner and simpler so what
i'm going to show you now is a bunch of
examples
of how code gets simpler and easier
probably faster
things like this now these are all the
obvious benefits these are like your
benefits
when you write more idiomatic python
however
there are broader non-obvious or less
obvious
things as well for example if you run an
open source project
it's easier to get people to contribute
to your project
if it doesn't look like a big mess if it
looks like nice code if you're like oh
if i work with this project i'm working
on some amazing code by smart people
you know one like probably the example
that stands out strongest is pi
pi right you know the thing you use when
you say pip install a thing
that has been around for many many years
and it's had traditionally a hard time
of getting
contributors the reason is it's
not built on the traditional one not
built on flask or pyramid or django or
any of those things it's just some like
homegrown http listener
socket thing and it's it's basically
like thousands of lines of code in one
file and people come along to contribute
to pi
pipi and make it better and they're like
whoa i don't actually don't want to work
on this this is a mess i'm out
and so they're actually reworking this
it's a major project
at psf to recreate
pipe i now you have pipi.org and they're
finally starting to move that over
that's written
in pyramid and using modern idioms and
guess what
they have more contributors the exact
same story applies to you if you work at
a company
right you want to keep your best
developers don't make them work on
crappy code right let them work on
amazing
projects and so this works either open
source or closed source
there's the same benefits i think all
right common question
always these talks can i get the code
that you're going to write yes you can
get the code
it'll be at github.com mike c kennedy
and then stuff
after that i'll put this back up later
all right are you ready what i hope to
do is just show you a bunch of examples
that are you can take as a broader
inspiration we're not going to touch on
everything that might or might not be
pythonic
but we'll start with some real simple
examples and we'll get increasingly
advanced to stuff that probably a lot of
you have not used
probably not seen maybe okay so let's
start something real simple string
formatting
how's that good you guys like it
is it going to run it's going to run
badly
type error but i mean technically it
runs so it'll run it'll say no
age is a integer you can't even do this
so we fix this of course
stir int much better all right this is
good
no this is not good uh this is the kind
of code you might write if you came from
say javascript or
c-sharp or something you tried the top
one it doesn't work so fine we'll do the
bottom one i guess python's a crappy
language that's how we have to do it
no it's just doing it wrong all right so
you can use the old
older style percent format as well but
certainly today this is sort of outdated
in the modern python sense but this this
still kind of okay but i wouldn't say
that it's so great so what do we do well
a lot of it starts with stringing out
format right
so here we can format the name and the
age get this to come out it's great
um if you don't care if you don't care
about reordering
it you can just put curly curly you
don't have to say zero one
the name nothing like that this is great
if you want to do replica
repetition or reordering of the
arguments you can say one
you know hi my name is curly one you're
uh hi
i'm curly one years old my name is curly
zero yeah currently one years old things
like that that's pretty nice
if you have a dictionary or you want to
use keyword arguments you can do a
little better
you can say format and give it uh
either a dictionary that you're
expanding the keywords or just keyword
arguments
and then you could say on curly day i
was working at curly office
and this is really nice because at least
with the keyword argument version you
can test that it's working
right it's very easy to read
however all of these things have been
replaced
by f strings how many of you use f
strings
ah for the record about third i would
say so very cool these are great right
so with f strings we have the shortest
way
right you just say f quote and then in
the curly braces go
arbitrary python expressions here you
can see we have curly name
and we have curly h plus one like next
year i'll be that
right so this is really cool because the
linters can say actually
that age is not defined it's called
years or something like that right so
you can actually check
that the formatting is going to work all
right so here's a real simple example of
how you might start out how you might
get better okay these also happen to be
the most high performance
way to create python strings as well so
very good all right merging dictionaries
let's
let's take a scenario some kind of web
app i've got a web app
and data is coming into your application
from multiple locations
you have the url which has the route
in it you know like my server slash
user slash seven right that seven is
passed as like say a user id or just id
here
in the query string you might have
question mark id equals
something in the forum post you have
data coming back so you want to just
create like one source of truth like
okay well
if these all these different places i
can get this information let's create
one dictionary that's like
the answer and we want to have a
priority here we want to have
route have the highest priority
something appears there first
we want the data to be there uh query to
have the lowest
lowest because people can just put
question mark junk on the end and mess
with your site and post is in the middle
so how do we do that well
it's cool we write some loops we're
going to create this new dictionary
we're going to go through
first the query copy the values over
then the post to copy the values over
and then the route and copy the values
over and because the order
we have the id that showed up in the
query is being
overwritten by the one in route so we
have our priority right
pythonic not pythonic nah so there's a
couple of
uh ways we could do it obviously there's
update and copy
so i could go and create this in one
that i could say m1 update with the
query update with the other
but there's actually a better shorter
way we can do this
let me do that how many are you familiar
that expression
and 20 25 okay so this does
exactly the same thing it recreates a
new dictionary called m1
copies all the values for query over
copies all the various posts over and
route and
the thing that goes at the end has
priority over the thing that goes before
it
so exact same thing much much simpler
right okay so
those are interesting speaking of
dictionaries
uh something closely related to them are
these keyword arguments
so here we've got to connect to our
database and let's see we're going to
give it a few pieces of information
we're going to give it
the username the server whether it
should use replication and whether it
should use ssl so
we're going to call it down here connect
m kennedy's user dbserver is that
yes use ssl true use replication false
wait is it the other way around which
which was it was that a problem
why is my company in the news is losing
all this data
so that's that's okay some of the time
but
like the last two true false values
which is which it's not totally obvious
so we could write this slightly
differently it's a little longer but
super obvious right we could say users
and kennedy servers that replicates that
use sl is that oh okay let's switch
those maybe
i don't know have to decide what you
really want
this is cool that we can do it and we've
been able to do it for a long time did
you know that you can
force people to do this
so we rewrite that function above and we
put that little star right there
that tells python you must write
the bottom one that's an error that's
fine how many of you guys know that star
did that 20 is that the same 20 percent
every time you guys are awesome
okay so this is really cool you can say
this
function is so super important i want
you to call it that bottom way
and if i try to do it the the way where
i don't use the keyword arguments
it says you passed four positional
arguments to this method
zero were expected error right
really cool okay so this this little
star of required keyword arguments is
super awesome
all right here's a function that defines
the fibonacci numbers any algorithm in
computer science has to somehow involve
the fibonacci numbers right 1 1 2 3 5 8
and so on
so there's a problem with this so right
it's not entirely
accurate how many numbers are in the
fibonacci numbers
infinite right how many are here not
infinite
well the problem is if i try to pass
some kind of infinity or something
really really big for limit
it's going to take that numbs list and
it's going to just keep filling it up
until you run out of time you run out of
memory something like that
okay so we can obviously fix this
by turning to a generator now we have an
infinite version of it that is actually
much more high performance
than it was before as well you guys use
yield
yield yeah awesome i'd say about half
yield is awesome
so this is really great sometimes though
you want to do recursion so
if i'm working with like any kind of
tree data structure a really natural way
to work with it is through recursion so
here i have a function called get files
taken a folder it'll get all the files
and then look for files in the
subdirectory
and notice down below it's actually
calling itself again but with the
subdirectory not the top level directory
right that's all good and this is a
generator so it's super efficient
however you can also as of
you can also use uh yield from right so
yield from says
here is a generator take all of the
items and give it back so what we're
saying in the first part is
well if it's a file here's an item from
the collection i'm looking for here's an
item that goes in my collection
when you get to yield from you say
here's a bunch of items in my collection
just add them all to what's getting
returned
apparently my mouse is tired okay so
yield from really cool thing
all right so there's these three these
sorry these four were the first four
because they have an interesting common
thread
between them all right
the common thread so the common thread
is that they're all only
available to you in python 3. right
not legacy python modern python so
there's been many examples of i would
love to use this library but it's only
available in python 2.
these i propose to you like these are
amazing language features
that are only available to you if you
switch to python 3.
and i think this is the move that's
actually kind of the momentum is already
going it's going downhill but i just
wanted to point this out as well
all right a couple others suppose i have
an iterable or some kind of
thing that is not not a list so i can't
call len
on it okay so here i'm going to like a
data layer i'm saying give me all the
measurements that are higher than 70
i get like something back that i can
loop over but it's not a list so len
doesn't work
so how do you count those yeah make a
loop
that's what i didn't see it was fine
totally awesome so
we could create this number we could
loop over it will add up
you don't have to worry about whether
it's a short and enter a long it's going
to overflow none of that stuff it's fine
right
well there's a better way what if i have
this and i can do it in one line
and come over here and write a little
inline generator that says i'm going to
sum up the number
one for each item and by the way
python makes me put a thing there but i
don't care about it so i'm going to put
underscore
right and in python when you have an
argument that you don't care about and
you want to tell python i don't care
about you
but it has to go here underscore right
really really nice feature okay so this
is good
let's talk about slicing slicing is
amazing it's something fairly unique to
python
and so on so let's go back to our our
finite fibonacci thing we're gonna turn
the list
and i'm gonna get a bunch back maybe i
only want the first five so we can write
this cool little code here
go to call the function bracket you know
either zero or nothing colon five
gives me a sub list zero uh
one one two three five cool right
what if it's a generator and i tried the
same thing
good no good
no good a lot of thumb down generator
object has no attribute
um thunder get item that's a bummer i
thought slicing was cool and i could do
this but apparently
it's only sort of cool well itter tools
bring slicing back for generators and
other things that don't have a len on
them right
so if you want to do the same thing as
we did before you can just import
intertools and say i slice
and what do you get back same thing
cool right okay
so where where did this inspiration for
what is pythonic come from
right i gave you sort of some of the
benefits of the beginning but
many people point to the zen of python
by tim peters
and they'll say well if you don't really
know what you should do you should just
type
import this and you get this
this is literally what comes up right
this is awesome another amazing thing
you can type
is import anti-gravity i don't know if
you've ever done that you need to do
that
but this this is more applicable right
now so import this and it says a few
things like
special cases aren't special enough to
break the rules
right that's good that means we kind of
decide upon one way doing things and so
on
although practicality beats purity so
these are this is a bit of attention
like
don't do this except for when you should
do it um
okay so i'll show you i'll leave you
guys with
one final example of where
where you might make this trade-off and
where you might think about making this
trade-off
all right so there's this really cool uh
blog post that came out a while ago
called hacking python's memory with
slots
how many of you know what dunder slots
means
now this is this is 10 15
okay so this is really amazing it's
definitely a way to break the rules but
to break them in an interesting and
productive
sense so there's this company that does
hotel
sort of recommendations and travel stuff
called oyster
i'd never use them but they have a cool
blog post
so they were running all sorts of
caching and stuff on their servers and
their servers were using about 25 gigs
of ram
and then they said oh and we changed
this one line of code and we saved nine
gigs of ram per server
and it was faster like oh what was that
one line because that's kind of cool
right
all right so let's go let's go forward
with this for a bit
how are we doing time i got a few
minutes this will work so
every bit of code that you saw us write
uh
some me talk about rather is available
like here's the string stuff
uh here's the dictionary stuff so this
will all be in the repo but the part i
want to focus on is this last one here
so the idea is we've got
a traditional class which i'm calling a
mutable thing
not super interesting but it has a
initializer
it takes four arguments it stores them
right there
yeah totally standard however when
people
come to python from languages really
especially the compiled languages like c
plus or java or net or something
this this expression here is is
mysterious like what does this mean
you're assigning to a variable the
variable doesn't exist but after this it
does
of course there's this convention of
creating things like this
but if you come over here and you make a
class
and you define
a dunder net for it
like that and you create one of them
let's call there's a little a
um oh yes of course one two three
and let's do a little b put a different
value there
that really just routes under to the
dictionary right
pretty straightforward yeah okay just a
sec
how's that so we have this dictionary
but this little b also has this
dictionary right
but the thing is
they're not the same every time you
instantiate an object
you're instantiating the dictionary and
the keys are copies of the fields
yeah that's fine that lets me go along
and do things like this
now i can make a dynamic and add stuff
to it however
if i'm not going to do that i'm going to
have millions of those in memory
would i want copies of the fields in
memory millions of times
probably the answer is no so basically
that's what slots
is it's a way to say these are the
fields i'm not going to change them
please don't make copies of the name all
the time
there's going to be these three values
or whatever
okay so here's a traditional class which
i'm calling a mutable thing and then
there's this one
all that i've changed is that little bit
right there it has
dunder slots set to the four values and
check this out if like i take away this
d
you see there's an error right here you
can't assign to this because you've
declared it only has three things a b
and c
and there's no d and there's no way to
add a d okay and there's a runtime error
like no you can't add a d
it has slots don't do that okay so this
literally line 26 that's the line
and the assumption is i cannot do that a
dot fun equals true
retroactively i have to agree upon what
goes in it that that's how most code
works
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a bunch of data a bunch of
these objects
how many check this out this is kind of
cool let's put the underscores here
all right this is a python 3 6 thing i
think
so we have a million and we're going to
create a million of them
and we're going to use first a tuple
which is okay
way better is a named tuple
then we're going to create uh the
regular class and finally we're going to
create the one that has the slots
we're going to look at two aspects how
long does it take to run how much memory
does it use to do that okay all right so
let's
let's go ahead and run this first one
here
and it's running and it ran in half a
second so i'll keep a little a little
history here for you
um tuple
0.5 seconds you know that's all right
and let's see how much memory it has
it's not running so we'll come down here
we'll come down here and we'll say
python spelling is hard okay so 209 megs
let's just do it real quick for the
others
let's go down and say you know what
tuple was fun
but we all know that named tuples are
way better
what's the trade-off here all right it
ran in 1.4 seconds so three times slower
granted
a million items that's a ton
name tuples equals 1.5
sec and memory
216. a little bit worse but not too bad
i'm willing to make that trade off if i
get better usability
so on how's it work for a regular class
let's try it on this one this is like
just no-nonsense standard python class
about the same amount of time however in
memory
293.
so class 1.5 memory is 293.
uh 293.
now final thing in this presentation
put some numbers today will it be faster
do you think
significantly not significantly how many
people say much faster okay
40 i'm gonna take the opposite to mean
not so fast so so we'll go over speed
memory it seems like it's gonna be
better right if we don't create one
million extra dictionaries with four
keys in it
it seems like that's less memory if we
just don't do that so
that's interesting but think about like
what would be the most efficient
representation it's got to be like the
non-name tuple right
it can't how can you get better than the
non-name tuple all right let's run it
and time a little faster so you're both
right that's awesome
and over here from memory we have
201 which is less than even the name
tuple
all right so here's one of these
although practicality beats purity
right it's you probably shouldn't do
this slots thing
almost ever but if it'll like let you
run
half as many servers maybe you should do
it every now and then right things like
that
all right so this was just uh sort of a
exploring
the whole import this
all right so all you got to do
thunder slots name the things off it
goes and there is no dunder dick
right there would be like an attribute
error or something if i tried to print
that out there's no dunder dam
all right so that's it guys